okay akash in all seriousness
you didn't get joe rogan canceled again
but you guys did have a fun conversation
great broadcast how do you feel about it
i felt good i didn't want to try too
hard i didn't want to push too much and
like but i felt like it was good i felt
like i did what i needed to do when i
got there you were excellent thank you
so much i mean this objectively and i'll
tell you something honestly i think i
texted this i didn't know i knew i was
going to be excited for you yeah i
didn't realize how
like happy and
exciting it was for like i had no i was
like blown away
yeah like i got emotional i did too but
you're supposed to you know at you
yeah this how supportive you've been
through this whole thing how much i said
this on rogan so more people heard it
but the amount of help this guy gave me
on the special he said a couple days
before it dropped um i got from 12 to 4
p.m i'll help you edit this guy taught
me how to elevate every aspect of the
special
till 4am 16 hours
that's what we do late but it was worth
it that's what we do for each other and
you spent hours with me like when we
were preparing for guy code and all
these things back in the day this is
just what we do but uh but i was just so
proud of you you're so eloquent so
articulate like yeah just great
perspective and like you were really
yourself there like i think a lot of
people go on rogue and they're so caught
up in like
what that moment is that it's very easy
to lose yourself yes you know what it
means like you're sitting in front of
the president and all you start to you
start to go like oh sure i guess maybe i
do share more views with you yeah right
and it's like you gave pushback he
started talking about the jfk
assassination and literally you just
went jojo
i stopped listening a while ago i had i
couldn't believe you said that
i couldn't believe it i was like this
guy's got balls
he has to pee back
and they did take a pee break i did i
had to stay true g's up i know you did
two and a half hours with him before a
pee break you can go 30 minutes on his
phone
what's up with that say what see how
little water i was drinking i didn't
notice dude the amount of focus i was
going in there with i was like i cannot
slip this guy
you know sometimes you'll say some [ __ ]
in like an argument or discussion or
whatever and as you're saying it you're
like oh there's a little hole in here i
hope they don't catch it yeah he catches
it
that's why i was so excited for you
going i was talking to kunal about this
because i bumped into him last night
okay yeah and i was just like
i think that
like you're not gonna go a comedian is
not gonna go on rogan's podcast and say
anything about cancel culture wokeness
etc that rogan doesn't already know he's
already spoken to the best experts on
this yes right he's spoken to the people
who get paid for a living just to think
about this stuff right so comedian
coming on right you're not gonna blow
him away with that right but you have
your specific experience right that he
doesn't know about he doesn't know it's
like to be an indian american dude right
and what you feel do you feel oppressed
do you feel offended by jokes etc like
he can't tell you how that feels and he
probably hasn't interviewed people who
have given that perspective right so you
got to be an expert yeah and it was this
really cool thing when he was like
listening and like really curious and
like you guys had this cool comedy
discussion but you still had this nugget
of information that he didn't have and
he was really curious about learning and
you just executed perfectly and you know
i don't maybe i'm fluffing you right now
but i just was so proud i've listened to
the episode maybe two times i just keep
scrolling back and forth waiting for you
guys to talk about me
[Laughter]
and then uh but no seriously it's just
it's so good and i think everybody
should go listen to it but like you were
so good so calm so like confident yeah i
was i was nervous as [ __ ] you didn't
come across
the things i i always hate when i press
too hard when you try too hard that's
the thing that i know i've done so i was
like do not think that just because so
many people are listening you need to
try too hard and push too hard to be
funny let the [ __ ] happen as it happens
don't try to make yourself somebody or
not and just be honest and authentic and
talk and if you don't agree obviously
you respect the [ __ ] out of this guy so
you're not going to be disrespectful
yeah so just to have a respectful like i
don't know what do you think about this
anything you wish you did differently
um there were certain things that like i
wish i had said little points i wish i
had made but like overall i just i wish
i didn't get them canceled
that's it that's the main thing so funny
there it came out that there's this
person who gets paid
to listen to every rogan podcast for
misinformation well that's the person
that did the article really i thought
those were different people no no so
alex patterson
was the person on twitter was the person
on twitter and that's the person that
kicked up the story in the first place
so the main tweet is
uh spotify's joe rogan and comedian
akash saying mock child sex abuse and
claim it's quote fine for boys to have
sex with adult women bro i think i got
brought up in that same thing because
they were going through past episodes
and literally exactly what's gonna
happen
is like we call this right it was like
first it's going to be racism the next
it's going to be misogyny your first i
was listening to your first rogan cause
i thought it was so good like to just
like mentally be like this is the
mindset yeah there's a moment where you
predict exactly what's going to happen
yeah like an hour and 28 minutes in you
say they when your ideas are too good
and big like to for them to compete with
they just make you radioactive and then
you literally said they're just going to
make you racist oh i don't need to talk
to joe rogan he's racist bro it's and
then i say i think transphobia yeah and
all these other things after that yeah
miles we'll give you the clip because
shifty just cut up the clip you've seen
everything you see in comedy it's like
oh i can't do that type of comedy so i'm
gonna make that comedy radioactive so
that this is the only type of comedy
that's allowed you know what i'm saying
it doesn't have to be kami it could
really be any kind of situation and so
you're just trying to carve out the
market share like ooh that comedy's
dirty that's edgy that's sexist that's
bigoted censor it censor it but it's
also like the same thing you see with
the right versus the left there's a lot
of people online from each side that
want to censor the opinions of the other
people instead of having a better
opinion yeah they want to shut that
opinion off and when they don't have a
better opinion they just make you
radioactive so they don't even have to
talk to you yeah hey joe rogan you're
racist what do you mean let's talk about
you're like i don't talk to races yeah
oh that was clever what you did i went
through that like the second i had an
opinion that went against the grain
immediately i'm labeled as something
that they don't even have to have a
dialogue with right they just shut you
down yeah oh you're a white supremacist
exactly oh you're all right yes oh
you're this you're that it's like a
magic trick it only works if you don't
know what they're trying to do but what
a job
yeah like your job is literally to sit
there and cancel rogan yeah
yeah that's the hardest part of that is
not liking the podcast and you're gonna
yeah it's too many different people on
there you have to like start liking it
you're gonna start getting perspective
yeah and then you're gonna have to quit
your job right or hate yourself
it's like those people who are um what
is it called spies for the mafia they
work for yeah
donnie brasco whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're a policeman but you're
undercover
yeah like or underpaid
but like i think what might happen with
some of them is like you actually start
to like fall in love with these people
i'm sure yeah you're with them all day i
think you can separate though the good
ones can
some sometimes if you're there long
enough you're gonna i mean if you're in
it and like you're learning
interpersonal [ __ ] that i get it but i
think if you're just observing or like
doing something you think is unethical
doesn't align with your moral code i
think you can remove yourself
yeah start doing some of those
activities with them
i mean he's doing 13 he's the rogan is
right here in his ears for 13 hours a
week yeah
at some point if you're actively
listening you're going to be like this
is pretty [ __ ] interesting yeah
you're at least going to have more
perspective yeah and you're going to go
well he definitely isn't what
everybody's saying right low-key this
could be the best possible thing
that person quits their job
it exposes everything they just get
another watchdog yeah they moved on they
got promoted they will but if those
people keep quitting it's like wait why
does this one job which is the easiest
job in the world
why do these people keep quitting and
then they'll do a think piece and it's
like i actually listened to the guy and
i found out wow it's like a lot of
unique voices on here he's trying to
have a good perspective sometimes having
same jokes but a lot of things he's
saying that are horrible or out of
context yeah yeah and to the an
eye-opening thing thank god he he asked
me how i was doing up top you were like
how did how do you open the door oregon
podcast when he asked me how i was doing
i just kind of laughed and i was like
buddy how are you doing and that was
like that was my genuine feeling but it
was such an interesting answer he said
it's a relief because i've known this
was out there and i've wanted to
apologize for it i've regretted it and
now i just get to do that so now that
that's out of the way they're really
scraping the bottom of the barrel it's
freedom you're scraping for a joke
conversation where we're laughing
talking about something everybody i
heard am ready the tiki wiki did this
[ __ ] like three weeks ago why is it
worse when this exact scenario happens
male student female teacher versus the
other way around they literally
pontificated why is it worse because
they all accepted that it was worse
we all accept that it's worse not
everyone is good and then somebody said
it was kind of a little like vivid but
he was like i think this is vivid but i
think when it's a female like a young
female she's the one getting penetrated
and that's why it seems so much more
visceral for us
yeah penetration is always worth worse
yeah because it's like female teacher to
female student
and they're just like rubbing you know
box lips yeah yeah
exactly
if they're just rubbing box lips bro
yeah they both throw on the clap cleats
kick one leg up on a wall
you know and just start clapping with
that labia dude
right
teacher and the student i'm talking
about a teacher that's in mba there we
go i'm talking about a teacher
i'm talking about a teacher that might
be 30 years old and a student might be
25. or yeah might be 31. they might be
31. it doesn't matter what year they are
but i know that they're older and i know
when the coochies start clapping bro
if they don't have the right clap clean
on they might slips fall all over the
place alex
it's an episode of whiplash don't do
that it's good you got wipe out whatever
that [ __ ] show is you know where
asians can't do things
you know the show right
right you are ken
that's mxt oh that's a ninja warrior i
don't like calling them all ninjas buddy
i feel like that's a little bit more
rich that's a little racist yeah alex i
expect better for you as a black man us
on that so what wipe out his americans
oh it's the american version of it okay
so american ninja warrior is what
man got me on that one
okay um but you feel good response has
been good it is funny with this person
alex patterson that's like
watchdogging yeah is that every i think
what'll happen more likely is that
every time that there's a stretch or a
reach to try to find something because
ultimately the job is maintained by
finding [ __ ] to get outraged by and
there's not a ton of stuff to get
outraged by so things like this for
example akash's tweet where this person
is trying to like put akash and joe in
this awful conversation all the replies
are like lol that's hilarious
oh this is a reach or i think it's funny
you should not take comedy that serious
or this account is joe rogan's best bits
compiled yeah like all the comments i
can't find one comment this is on
twitter
and people following like a very like uh
i don't know like liberal cancelling
kind of person it's great for joe yeah
this is good yeah that's great literally
paying attention to him is what the
cancellers don't do
that is the problem that's what
canceling is yeah yeah it's like you
don't know the full picture of a human
and you're getting them out of there off
of the worst thing that they said in
their life right so in no context if you
have someone who all of a sudden has
context
and they're holding the uh what's it
called the the the release button for
the guillotine but now they have context
they're like do i really need to write
this whole article he was clearly joking
and 10 seconds later said it was
[ __ ] yeah
now if only someone did that for the
news
[Music]
why don't we have one person who just
listens to the news 24-hour news cycle
and just writes down every time they get
some wrong we got a teenager that tracks
elon musk's jet but we don't have an
adult that's just watching cnn and going
this is [ __ ] yeah you should have
one for all of them fox news msnbc every
single one
when i was in middle school i had a
teacher named mr davis and he would give
extra credit for when we found out he
was wrong oh yeah we had one of those
that's cool yeah like he was like fact
check me if i say some [ __ ] go read it
and he's like sometimes i'm gonna say
some [ __ ] that's wrong
that's dope like on purpose yeah
if you guys are paying attention
and that's a little while he's a wild
boy this dude was a wild thing that was
a little but i've never seen somebody
control a room like literally i get
comedy things from him really the guy
was in eighth grade american history
teacher race are you huh
the guy's just like what
why is that relevant to history so in
american history very good point
uh but like i've learned more in
american history than any video than
than anybody else i've ever like taken
classroom but like the way he controlled
that classroom it was unbelievable dude
like everybody nobody spoke
never cared to be anybody's friend never
tried to ingratiate himself to the class
at all that's a good teacher and he i
mean the craziest kids the kids who are
like getting in fights all that kind of
stuff
walked dude we weren't even allowed to
enter the class until he said everybody
lined up outside the class
stoic i didn't even think i saw him
smile the whole time
it was absolutely it was like i was like
oh my god you can control a room just
with like pace and intensity and what is
it you wanted his respect like all the
people in the class i just learned that
like silence is valuable
but why did you all fall in line for him
what do you think it was i think that he
didn't care if we liked him and i think
that he cared uh i think that we felt
like it was there would be consequences
for our actions and he wasn't to be
played around with and he made class
very
uh easy to succeed in he told us the
things he wanted us to write down and
he's like write this down write this and
then kept talking write this down write
this down and all of us got this sense
like as long as i'm here and i'm writing
down the things that he's telling me
and i get tested on these things i can
do well